okay guys okay guys um jaisa have a
[ __ ] dress I just tried to play this
game and chroma knows crashing for some
reason so then I decided to play it on
edge that was a [ __ ] nightmare but we
got this guy firefox okay chip why
psychobabble we're playing a game called
a temple of no by the company crows
crows crows and this is awesome company
they make like Stanley parable and the
beginner's guide all that [ __ ] that's
actually like clever so here we go here
we go Oh before we start designed it
illustrated by Dominic Johanna that's
him right there hey look you could tell
he's like designing here oh sorry and
we're gonna voice act my william p 0
like okay that's that's why I almost
ceased like talking okay but companies
made it twine she had to click on the
line or its play oh yeah when that was
perfect click on auto I north supply it
I can't let's do this hello this story
what plays owner of me while I'm
explaining what's about to go down this
story you're good again punch it listen
this is twine you're acting like you
never put at wine before as a place just
mmm alright this story my friend disturb
you but if you have a strong stomach
smart brain box and that sound like a
head I'm not a penis out like a human
head and a coal face and perhaps you're
brave enough to hear it a storm of air
well you brave like I'm like a sailor
enough lab this isn't matt you are you
ready yes yes I'm ready oh good yeah
this is story I properly happened it
took place a long time ago like just
last week so it's a good one here we go
now a big fat buck okay let's get out
this da state-owned to hear this
fantastic tale it's called know they
shed the brave Explorer like a seller
the jungle of doubt and the temple of
now ok let's begin hello the three guys
okay so this is a magical buckets magic
powers to be incredible
reliable is that a frog holy [ __ ] are
you a woman a bloke or fraud I'm frog i
canna level with you you're playing a
real game here I don't read a lot of
[ __ ] about subverting the
expectations with time games for the man
and woman options and to be honest I
don't think those jokes at braylin this
frog star is actually genuine and what
this whole game is about so in fact I'm
gonna stop putting any actual effort
into writing the other branch of
dialogue I'm gonna focus on tally on
this one all time for picking the
interesting option hello frog I hope you
like it let's go Oh rivet I can relate I
Cathy all oh the frog princess lived in
slimy bottom small fishing village down
in the heart of Yorkshire's now it's bad
a little small boat around and ferried
smaller animal seat to and fro each side
of the pond and on Sundays it pedal down
to the animal market and buy 12 fly
cakes one for each of its tadpole
children but this sunday was different
there was a strange taste in the air as
a pedal down the stream in it no and
it's cold-blooded froggy heart that i
missed the days of auld adventure in a
dude that has traveled the world
explored new non froggy areas okay um
many of his discoveries had shaped the
development of frog culture and frog
history but after enjoying the quiet
life ragga and it was time to step foot
into the world through venture once more
there's a crash course on our froggies
old adventure history oh [ __ ] yes a
Younker froggy um the frog princess lost
an eye and a massive [ __ ] fight with
a baboon yes I say that's the Batman I
guess they killed baboon it's badass
shrug okay now don't [ __ ] with the Frog
you what's travel to an arnica install
22 penguin eggs very illegal the master
stuff and it could sneak up on you break
your neck easily like a really easily
okay um shut I frog legs are we jumped
over an entire fence like a human-sized
fans to skate the Frog prison compound
set up by the UK government out of frog
uncover their equal plot attempt
rig the Frog elections and then it went
back and say it all the other frogs and
you should be thanking at ragi eyes okay
you ready now to get out straight into
the story Oh shed um frog jungle
transition and audio shut you know
seeing this yes depression quest didn't
have this all right let's go right into
the store the Frog Prince has entered
the jungle of doubt on its journey to
find the man that says all things that
ever have been or well day I do map form
you know hello Oh LTA right there um the
map was legendary the old tale spoke
about it yeah you know the old tales
yeah anyway anyway so the frog princess
know if proper wanted the map to tell it
the secrets of the universe if it
brought the map back to civilization at
what shall I achieve greatness it now
and it's kyle blooded slimy frog heart a
temple that health and map let's class i
said dang o fire this dangerous okay
hope the jungle down here we go frog
princess looked up down all around
what's up what's up up in the mossy
green leaves of the giant jungle trees
at rich high above it they spread out
and sometimes you could barely see the
Sun it was in the heart of the jungle
and you know it surprises an air down
down down on the ground I didn't know I
was looking down but it could say some
dirt a bit of gum wrapper some tours or
jungle resin hell lots on the floor
clean up your little kids don't pollute
the environment I say that so all around
all around the jungle I had to cut
through the leaves and brushing floor
and jungle the brace in order to get to
the temple that it was going to I guys
cut through yeah okay well the Frog cut
through the leaves and brush and flora
and Jung gonna braise it I'm not about
some [ __ ] the frog princess thought of a
house feet were hurting it a bet you
know wish she'd bought some jock shoes
the shoes at braid trademark it
continued the tank
the frog princess thought about how its
knows what's at j if it bought geox use
the shoes i prayed trademark it would
likely have it's a compra feet that i
want to be bothered by it maker knows it
and continued to thank jayhawks the
shoes that bread the frog princess
wasn't there yet it still had much more
John got to get there so it him you can
say that the possibility at life was
futile you know thought about futility
for a while I'll bet remember that it
wasn't any fun to think about it and
thought about doing it a little dance oh
yeah take it down Crockett's okay I
stopped the magic they put a word up I
can't help progress is thought still
ways to go it I thought about some
Shannon sang a little song okay if you
don't you will know that you lay some
time I can hit lyrics aside sang at the
dinner I'm getting the laughs I'm
pushing past the tray
I'm slashing with this brush florin
jungle the brains a name is the frog
princess and I'm saying a sign to take
at the time while I travel along the
path to the temple of Hope now that is
where i am going to gal
I am Cat in the lace I am pushing past
the chase I'm / in a wet days grunts
floor and jungle that brace yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I've got an intervention
today this game was really really for
the play Trucking's get me fun I will
shout check out this singing in the
jungle uptown yeah I'm cutting the lace
and budget passed the chase I / annoyed
days brush floor and jungle to braise
yeah yeah yeah soon I'll be at the
temple up now it's got lots of chowder
and I'm going to go take some back to my
home town keep it for myself enough [ __ ]
Danny around I'm cutting the layers that
impression pastor Jay
and slashing away at day
browse floor and John got a break I got
out he didn't sing this time and you
know you let yourself down you need to
let you so have fun he left i'll try and
be so sorry i said if you can sing
softly scroll up trend that we did it if
he did something well done your call now
I did it did it all I thought about so
shout at sang a little song you've said
the possibility i was futile like yeah
slide I got he found it up yeah he's
[ __ ] up why don't you put his hat on
the one [ __ ] up i am a frog prince has
emerged from the jungle and saw the
temple um now
the frog princess Marvel addadd his
magnificence probably built by the
Aztecs debt
like it was that big anyway so I just
take some coffee I left kind of stairs
there's we go and then
all right that's ample time and Mary
explores out at lac I didn't touch
carefully walked around down a dusty ad
or spooky quarter of the temple being
extra careful not to touch anything it
arrived in a large hall with varied ours
very hey Darce very hey it as well as
though very dark I can't read it's
election time everybody left middle or
anti left oh [ __ ] oh that's a ver for
symbol that's the ohm and that is a
repair a little [ __ ] I feel the air for
oh [ __ ] it's a spike where my respect
Mulligan no got um Webster's dictionary
defines spike is a very large snail at 1
over Rho pointed irons placed to read
passage one of several mental projection
sentence so over he'll was shout to
improve not that doesn't a lot here I
don't think it's anything is room turn
back around okay um was doing the anti
left on oh [ __ ] I just snakes I want a
pool party I like how he's cute Oh is my
mind I can't snake for we hit actual
Gabe lie like he can't make snake and
why Ken yeah yeah well let's talk to the
specs hey mr. snake nice thanks huh and
I haven't a cool time I'll treasure in
here though unless you count a bunch of
snakes less treasure i charged it i may
I like that and what's that personally
don't okay um just be taken it got
scared back in here yes okay guess
you're done the middle and took the big
all room okay Wow more stairs a hair
let's climb them climbing up up up yes I
could get remember back at the start of
this trying game when you picked sailors
storm blah blah it's a good times
fifteens are real birthday excited
screen at the back section
yeah no doors like to the right have an
outdoor truly bring us what we want in
life how coffee good good perhaps up
some inning of this tale that you can go
through a jungle sing a son climb some
long stairs check a bunch of rims and
stell you'll never find what you're
looking for oh well that makes you think
huh that makes you think Nick Jay thank
ah yes the end oh wait now there's
another door at the throwing at Trent
Lestat we entered the door and found oh
the great leaders chain brother the
ultimate made up now now on the same was
a toy frog right so long hello oh nice
to meet you hello sorry one sec money to
write the Great layer his voice echoed
through their room and he listened
Ellison some horn and proceeded to
Ashton I'm at his anchor day huh so the
frog princess decided to kill him holy
[ __ ] what a badass [ __ ] it's a
little bit now that Kelly McGarrett
later it become my great lanta and and
violate that explores oh holy [ __ ] look
but dinna touch oh no
how can he forgot that explores up it's
a tray and pour en donde French um now
is the great little laws approach it
right the worshipers new God frog
decided right there now it was
cut the map and escape back to
civilization 5
but then I thought the frog princess
dead no actually the fog queen that's
why I dad okay that's rightful I'm I'm
all the frog princess and that should
happen to me I don't know what lessons I
learned over i learned her lesson and
all but i got the map I got it that's
given me many pieces of insight and
because you've heard my tail and listen
to my words of wisdom I'll tell you one
piece right now the wisdom is have you
ever played a game in entwine like
walnuts actually got nada just I good
for a 2-1 game oh well that's sad that's
that's am thanks you're playing this is
eyewitness Danielle's and written with
the student produced and hosted on a geo
bellow the source code every its housing
free sound sound snap the dancing okay a
bother saying got cut where games join
the secret email club ik clear to play
again kisses and hugs and kisses and
hugs your friends at cause chaos chair
now welcomes the game I hope you enjoy
the temple up now now here's a picture
of mouth of the skull huh thank you
dips out for her Amish